У середу Росія звинуватила Україну в невдалій спробі замаху
на президента Володимира Путіна і пригрозила відповісти.
У ніч на 3 травня два безпілотні літальні апарати
атакували московський Кремль.
У Москві заявили, що за цією операцією стоять США.
У відповідь у Білому домі спростували причетність до цієї атаки
та заявили, що Вашингтон не заохочує і не дозволяє Україні
завдавати ударів за межами своїх кордонів.
Президент України Володимир Зеленський одразу заявив,
що Київ не має жодного відношення до інциденту,
відео якого було опубліковано у російських соцмережах.
У правдивості інформації Кремля одразу засумнівався
і держсекретар США Ентоні Блінкен.
Ці повідомлення я жодним чином не можу підтвердити.
Ми просто, просто не знаємо.
По-друге, я б сприймав усе, що походить від Кремля,
з дуже великою часткою скепсису.
Тож давайте спочатку подивимося, якими будуть факти.
При цьому ми залишаємо Україні право вирішувати,
яким чином вона захищатиме себе і як вона намагатиметься
повернути свою територію, яку незаконно захопила в неї Росія
за останні 14 місяців.
Відреагували на інцидент і в ЄС.
Жозеп Боррель закликав не використовувати його
як привід для подальшої ескалації.
Нас непокоїть те, що це може бути використано для того,
щоб виправдати більший призов людей,
солдатів, нові напади на Україну.
Найважливіше, що ми маємо продовжувати робити
- це підтримувати Україну військово, політично та економічно,
і найкращим рішенням для війни, єдиним рішенням для війни є те,
щоб Росія припинила атаку та вивела свої війська з України.
Чимало західних аналітиків впевнені:
якщо за атакою справді стоїть Київ,
то, швидше за все, її метою був зовсім не замах на Путіна,
а наочна демонстрація того,
що Україна здатна пробити оборону російської столиці й навіть Кремля
- робочої резиденції російського президента.
Це може бути символічний удар у саме серце Москви,
щоб продемонструвати, що по суті жодна частина європейської Росії
не захищена від українських атак.
І очевидно, що напад на Кремль має великий символізм,
враховуючи, що 9 травня Росія має провести прямо там масштабний парад…
На двох із численних відеороликів, опублікованих на російських каналах соціальних мереж,
видно два об'єкти, що летять до купола Сенатського палацу
- однієї з найвищих точок кремлівського комплексу.
Україна має кілька типів безпілотників, здатних на це.
Наприклад, нещодавно розроблений безпілотник UJ-22
може справді долати такі відстані.
Він створений на базі комерційного дрона,
який вони придбали в Китаї - вантажної моделі Mugin-5,
яку можна купити в інтернеті та переобладнати у військовий безпілотник.
Він може пролетіти кілька сотень кілометрів
і вже використовувався у попередніх атаках.
Американські фахівці кажуть, що відеозаписи можуть бути справжніми,
хоча деякі західні аналітики заявили, що, можливо,
Росія сама інсценувала інцидент, щоб звалити провину на Київ
і виправдати масований удар, наприклад,
по резиденції Володимира Зеленського в Києві.
Зараз обговорюється, чи це не було інсценовано як привід для того,
щоб виставити Україну як свого роду терористичну державу.
Я думаю, що це трохи надумано.
Адже така акція підриває спроби представити Росію як безпечну,
потужну державу заради якогось неясного послання,
якогось неясного приводу, щоб потім атакувати українців,
коли, відверто кажучи, росіяни не так уже й багато можуть зробити,
бо я маю на увазі, що вони не збираються на цьому етапі переходити до нападів
на українські міста чи мирне населення.
Адже вони вже це роблять.
А от в американському Інституті вивчення війни (ISW)
навпаки вважають напад на Кремль інсценуванням.
Цю думку поділяють і деякі німецькі експерти.
Дуже підозріло виглядає "негайна і скоординована" реакція Кремля
на те, що сталося. На думку авторів огляду, малоймовірно,
що обидва безпілотники могли подолати кілька рівнів протиповітряної оборони
та "бути так збитими прямо над Кремлем,
щоб забезпечити ефектні кадри".
Якби атака безпілотника не була інсценована зсередини країни,
це стало б несподіванкою для російської влади,
і так швидко підготувати реакцію на цю подію вони б не змогли.
Адже досі російська влада реагувала повільно і незлагоджено
на принизливі для них поразки на фронті та атаки безпілотників.
Так чи інакше, Кремль тепер спробує використати цей наратив нібито замаху на Путіна
для того, щоб дістатися самого Зеленського, зазначають аналітики.
Росія намагалася зробити це від початку війни.
Є багато інформації, що вказує на те, що кілери з російських спецслужб
відстежували Зеленського та його родину.
Тож багато аналітиків схиляються до того,
що атака безпілотників навряд чи була спланована Кремлем,
але й цей сценарій розглядається як один із можливих.